[Música]
eeuu anunció que pedirá la inmediata
extradición del capo mexicano rafael
caro quintero uno de los diez prófugos
más buscados por las autoridades de ese
país el antiguo líder del desaparecido
cártel de guadalajara fue capturado este
viernes en el estado de sinaloa
el gobierno colombiano anunció la muerte
de alias iván mordisco un líder de las
disidencias de la guerrilla de las farc
durante un operativo del pasado fin de
semana sin embargo el instituto nacional
de medicina legal y ciencias forenses
informó que el cuerpo del jefe
guerrillero no está entre los que han
sido identificados tras la operación
militar
el presidente de chile gabriel bordi se
anunció que en caso de que la nueva
constitución sea rechazada en el
plebiscito del próximo 4 de septiembre
volverá a convocar un nuevo proceso
constituyente dice y el gran apoyo
popular por la nueva carta magna que
impulsaría a reintentarlo
gracias por continuar con nosotros aquí
en france 24 mi nombre es juan pupiales
es momento de repasar las noticias más
destacadas del continente americano la
marina mexicana arrestó este viernes a
rafael caro quintero uno de los líderes
más importantes del narcotráfico y quien
lideró al desaparecido cártel de
guadalajara una de las organizaciones de
este tipo más poderosas en los años 80
quintero de 69 años cayó en choix una
localidad al norte del estado de sinaloa
uno de los bastiones del tráfico de
estupefacientes en el país fue una
sabueso militarmente entrenada a la que
halló al capo entre unos arbustos es
recordado sobre todo por el asesinato y
tortura del agente de la dea enrique
kiki camarena en 1985 desde la
administración del presidente
estadounidense a job hay de celebrar una
noticia y anunciaron que lo van a pedir
en extradición
el arresto de hoy es la culminación del
trabajo incansable de la dea y sus
socios mexicanos para llevar a caro
quintero ante la justicia por sus
presuntos delitos incluida la tortura y
ejecución del agente especial de la dea
enrique kiki camarena estaremos buscando
su extradición inmediata a los eeuu para
que pueda ser juzgado por estos crímenes
en el mismo sistema de justicia que la
gente especial camarena murió
defendiendo
el ministro de defensa de colombia diego
molano informó que el ejército mató el
fin de semana pasado al jefe de las
disidencias de la antigua guerrilla de
las farc néstor gregorio ver a fernández
alias iván mordisco la operación tuvo
lugar en un área rural de san vicente
del cagüán en el departamento del
caquetá al sur del país el ministro
calificó el hecho como la estocada final
a las disidencias sin embargo el
instituto nacional de medicina legal y
ciencias forenses de colombia informó
que tras el operativo militar ha
recibido nueve cuerpos siete de ellos
han sido identificados entre ellos hay
dos menores de edad pero el cuerpo de
mordisco no se encuentra entre ellos
esta operación con los resultados que
van a ser presentados en la mañana de
hoy tenía por objetivo neutralizar a uno
de los principales cabecillas de las
disidencias de las farc que nunca entró
al acuerdo de la habana y cuya
trayectoria criminal tema de más de 30
años en el sur del país se había
convertido en un azote para esa región
de colombia
llegaron a guatemala los restos mortales
del primero de los 22 nacionales que
murieron en la tragedia registrada el
pasado 27 de junio en texas cuando se
hallaron los cuerpos de 52 migrantes que
perdieron la vida en un camión desde
antigua nuestro corresponsal en
centroamérica andrés suárez con los
detalles
el canciller guatemalteco mario buscar o
presidió este viernes la llegada en
ciudad de guatemala de pasqual was
jacques y pack primera víctima re patria
niño de 13 años que fue asfixiado en el
camión de san antonio texas sus padres
casimiro y marie así como su abuela
manuela recibieron el cuerpo para
trasladarlo a su pueblo de origen desde
donde partió hace algunas semanas con la
esperanza de buscar un futuro mejor en
eeuu el canciller búcaro dijo que
ayudaran financieramente a las 22
familias guatemaltecas que sufrieron
esta tragedia pero se mostró evasivo
entre las preguntas de la prensa sobre
qué está haciendo guatemala en materia
para frenar la migración y evitar otra
tragedia de este calibre mañana llegarán
otros dos cuerpos de adolescentes en una
repatriación lenta si se la compara con
la de mexico que esta semana ya recibió
23 de los 26 fallecidos mexicanos en
esta tragedia por lo cual familiares y
amigos han podido llevar a cabo los
respectivos funerales eeuu tiene en este
momento cuatro capturados presuntos
autores de este crimen
judicializado se enfrentaría en la pena
de muerte y es que actualmente esta
región de centroamérica y méxico
enfrenta un record de flujo migratorio
tan solo en el 2022 se han identificado
1.4 millones de indocumentados
intentando cruzar hacia eeuu muchos de
ellos poniendo su vida en riesgo al
ponerse en manos de los traficantes de
personas conocidos como los coyotes y
polleros
en eeuu de la cámara de representantes
votó este viernes a favor de restablecer
el derecho al aborto en el país luego de
la decisión del tribunal supremo de
derogar el histórico fallo de roe versus
wait que aseguraba el derecho a la
interrupción del embarazo a nivel
federal este nuevo proyecto fue aprobado
por los representantes demócratas pero
tiene pocas posibilidades de convertirse
en ley ya que no cuenta con la mayoría
necesaria en el senado en donde
demócratas y republicanos se dividen los
escaños al 50%
el presidente de chile gabriel pobres
aseguró que impulsará un nuevo proceso
constituyente en caso de que el próximo
4 de septiembre se rechace la nueva
carta magna en un referendo boris se
apoya en que casi el 80% de la población
pidió un cambio de constitución por lo
que se habría de encontrar el camino
para conseguirla andrés grana de ello
nos cuenta más el texto más vendido por
estos días en chile
los vendedores ambulantes venden decenas
de ejemplares a diario como cuánto se
vende en cordial
un 80 el libro que contiene 388
artículos incluye temas sobre los
derechos sociales el género la política
y el medio ambiente atiza la
polarización que vive el país
sudamericano y ha despertado gran
interés entre los ciudadanos no toda la
gente se va a leer
es súper bien
hay gente de buena fe que
nos vemos sobre esto
[Aplausos]
esta nueva constitución cuyo texto será
refrendado en un plebiscito el 4 de
septiembre reemplazaría a la actual que
data de la dictadura de augusto pinochet
y que causa rencillas entre la población
por consagrar un modelo económico
neoliberal
orientado al mercado que llevó a chile a
un crecimiento económico durante décadas
pero que dejó de lado las políticas
sociales ocho de cada diez chilenos
votaron a favor de redactar una nueva
constitución hace dos años tras las
fuertes protestas sociales que
sacudieron al país pero el apoyo ha
caído en los últimos meses debido a
algunas propuestas consideradas
radicales ya las controversias que
rodean a la asamblea encargada de
redactar el texto
no nos movemos de sudamérica en perú el
pleno del congreso votó a favor de una
reforma constitucional para el retorno
de la bicameralidad que será decidido en
un referéndum con 71 votos a favor 45 en
contra y 6 abstenciones el pleno del
legislativo voto da la controvertida
propuesta del último en el último día de
la legislatura sin embargo el presidente
de la comisión de constitución para
patricia juárez indicó que pedirá una
reconsideración de la votación para
eliminar el trámite de ir a un
referéndum la bicameralidad fue
eliminada de una reforma constitucional
de 1993 por el entonces presidente
alberto fujimori
seguimos en este país porque por primera
vez en la historia la corte suprema
autorizó una aután hacia el fallo
dictado el jueves permite a la psicóloga
anna estrada el acceso a una muerte
asistida
autorizan eutanasia en perú a na estrada
de 45 años que ha luchado contra una
enfermedad degenerativa y terminal yo
creo que la corte suprema de justicia le
permitiera acceder a este
cuatro jueces votaron a favor y dos en
contra en un fallo que confirma una
decisión judicial previa me siento muy
satisfecha
muy agradecida
por qué
cuando empecé esto
no tenía mucho miedo mucho temor de que
no resultara o de que fuera
de repente todo en contra y más bien
resultó que recibí mucho apoyo hay
muchísima gente de a pie
he conocido a muchas personas muy
valiosas
y eso enriquecido este proceso la mujer
psicóloga de profesión padece polibio
cities desde los 12 años una enfermedad
que desgasta los músculos y no tiene
cura cuando cumplió 20 años empezó a
usar silla de ruedas debido a su
debilidad para caminar su abogado es
defensor del pueblo peruano aplaudió la
decisión en la corte declarar o fundado
el derecho a la muerte digna es un
precedente fundamental es el primer caso
y ese irrevocable le permite a estrada
poder tomar decisión de poner fin a su
vida en un momento determinado en perú
los de la mayoría de la población es
católica muchos conservadores se oponen
a esta práctica en latinoamérica sólo
colombia aprueba la eutanasia con
intervención médica países como chile
méxico o argentina tienen regulaciones
que permiten a los pacientes rechazar
tratamientos que prolonguen la vida
artificialmente terminamos así esta
emisión informativa la información
continua aquí también en france 24 punto
com
[Música]